our nischelle Turner was exclusively on
the set we're back action
Murphy Corky miles and Frank are
launching a new new show she's like my
older sister we love each other we love
each other alive et is first on the set
with the cast and first with what you'll
see in the debut episode and let's just
say mr. president you better take cover
you talked about once you went on a date
with Donald Trump in college right one
day one day 18 or 19 18 probably so I
think at a plot line should be Murphy
had gone on a date with him yeah yeah
it's happened there's one detail about
Candace's date apparently that that
isn't in the show that I really think is
great it turns out the honored date with
Trump he was decked out in maroon like
maroon shoes maroon suits three-piece
suit maroon limo apparently Candace
Instagram that right down there shooting
episode four called Murphy - but want to
know her on set secret must have faith
makes her breakfast every day so we got
the guys that chopped him up Mayo I had
a little olive oil Mayo simple a dash of
dill and mustard here not that much and
you scoop it out so how much do you look
forward to this bagel a dream about it
mouth starts foaming there you go okay
it's all for you how about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]